hello folks if you can hear me if you
can see me
please let me know i had a big glitch
so
here
if you can hear me if you can see me
can you hear me
i hope you can hear me
okay
major glitch i have no idea what
happened miracle that i was able to fix
it i still hope i'm online
that you can see me and hear me
oh i'm getting uh
errors from youtube
so i don't know what's going on
i hope you can still see me and hear me
low volume
let's see
volume volume volume
volume
i got volume max at max
i have no idea what's going on today
volume is fine can you hear me can you
see me i get all kinds of error messages
from youtube
uh all my equipment checks out okay i
was able to fix the problem i don't know
what i fixed but it got fixed but the
question is can you hear me can you see
me
okay
all i can ask is that you raise the
volume somehow
i'll try to speak up
okay anyways
happy new year
merry christmas and happy new year happy
rope here okay
well let's celebrate
hopefully this year uh
we get more people involved in uh in the
rope model
anyways let me get started since
uh since i'm a little behind
i didn't expect to have this major
problem
okay so what was this year about this
year was about this
this was about delta and the omicron
okay
we started out with delta and we ended
up with omicron
and if you look at it uh they look very
much the same i would say
okay so i don't know
uh in this mat and this these kinds of
matters i consider myself a total
ignoramus okay so i'm not going to boast
or anything but just objectively by
looking at this i would say they they're
very much the same
in fact someone came in and asked the
following or said the following said
that um the omicron is the common cold
okay
and
when i when i looked at um
when when i looked at the uh the
viruses
they do look the same look if you look
at the flu virus it looks very much like
the omnichrome virus
uh can someone tell me what the
difference is at least from a structural
standpoint they look exactly the same or
very much the same
now maybe internally that's what i'm
assuming the molecules are structured
differently
and so they have different properties
okay that's all i can think of otherwise
i would say that
you know what we got in front of us is
it's just a common virus
okay and again
i'm ignorant in the matter so i'm not
going to put my hand in the fire for it
i'm just saying that
objectively they look the same
hopefully someone out there
knows a little more and can tell you
exactly what is different about those
two viruses
uh now there is a possibility i want you
to think about this um
you know uh the
united states accuses china of
creating this thing in the lab in wuhan
and
wuhanians
they're accusing the united states of
bringing the stuff over there was a
meeting of military people
a get-together uh worldwide wrote
worldwide get together
military people in 2019 i think it was
august of 2019
in wuhan
and
uh the chinese are saying that the
americans brought that and threw it in
there you know after preparing it in
their intelligence lab
and the americans say the opposite it's
the chinese who
created in the lab and spread it from
wuhan
okay these are mafias uh that they just
point their fingers at each other um
i
you know it's it doesn't concern me
because we're never gonna find out who's
right it's just gonna be finger-pointing
right
but the issue here is that if this is
just a common cold i can imagine a lab
just modifying something in there
on the virus of a common whole cold for
those of you who believe in viruses and
that they do damage et cetera et cetera
et cetera well if they can modify
the virus just a little bit and turn it
into this
you know covet thingy well yeah then it
has different properties and etc etc so
i can believe that that could have been
a um
something manufactured in the lab
but now keep in mind the following
uh
you know wuhan is a city of 11 million
people
okay if you look at the entire
metropolitan area it's 19 million people
they never had uh covet over there
they never they they just found this out
what in 2020 and what was it 2020 i
think it was the start of this thing
i mean is this just when this came up
no one ever caught this thing
in all these hundreds of years wuhan has
been around for
centuries
no one ever caught this thing
uh could it be a last-minute mutation
out there in the chicken coop you know
uh chicken has uh the common cold
turns it into the covet co
virus
i don't know but it's something you
should think about
anyways i'd rather think of uh not this
past year which was pretty good for me i
want you to remember that you know been
online for now 13 years going on 14
years
and i think i did pretty good uh why you
say bill you don't have too many
followers
um
hopefully i don't have any followers i
you know i think it's creepy
i don't want anyone following me uh no
but the fact that some people have
understood the theory
and a lot of them uh liked the theory
and that was my only goal really
remember you know when you're fighting
the establishment it's very very
impossibly hard
to
to get your theory across so when you
look at it from that point of view i've
had
quite a bit of success okay
and my success is not how many people i
recruit there i said if i can
you know
show one person and that person
understands and likes the theory i'm
okay
and i've had a few of them and so you
know it's it's up for you to take it
to wherever you want to take it you know
it's up to you
and uh yeah i've had also detractors a
lot of people who attacked me and that's
that's fine there's that that's their
job
okay but anyways i'd like to think of
the coming year as the gear in which the
rope comes across to more people and
i'll call it the year of the road 2022
okay
and uh some people might say what is
this rope thinking about especially
those people who are not uh familiar
with what's going on in this channel
okay
and so i have to go with a lot of stuff
that we did this year but you know i
gotta condense 365 days into a few
minutes okay and so let's start here
okay what we've got is
a
not only a new version of light and
gravity we have a new language okay
we've defined critical words that we
believe are necessary
to
provide physical interpretations in
physics
we've redefined physics because we say
that physics is not about running
experiments
or
[Music]
or measuring doing equations
uh physics is about physical
interpretations exclusively
okay
people want to know how the universe
works
wants to know how gravity works want to
know how electricity works what how
magnetism work
how light works
and in order to do that you i say you
need a mediator
you need an object you need a thing
that mediates that transaction
okay so that's the bottom line
and uh so not only have we defined visit
we we went one further
step and said we are redefining what
science is
okay and science is not again about
doing measurements and running
experiments and putting out equations or
whatever
science is a little more than that or
better said it's parallel to that that
none of that has anything to do with
science
okay so
i'm not saying you got to agree with it
i don't think say that you have to
believe in it i'm just saying that's
what we say a science in this channel
okay so we have a different version of
what science is what physics is what
light gravity etc is okay
and you don't have to agree we're not
asking you to agree we're asking you to
understand okay and so this is how we
break up science okay here it is okay we
say that science is what
rational
explanations okay that's what we say
that science is about and it's divided
in two branches only two and
not
not into ten different branches but only
two and from these two these are the two
major headings from those spring
or spring uh all the other uh
subcategories okay we have on one hand
we have physics and the other one we
have philosophy okay
what is physics about well it's rational
explanations of causes and mechanisms
and in order to provide
uh rational explanations for causes and
mechanisms you do need objects you need
to have a thing a mediator okay
especially for the force of pull
okay
on the other hand philosophy it uh is
not what everybody thinks is philosophy
which is what everybody from uh i don't
know aristotle or plato uh all the way
to uh ayn rand and some of the modern
philosophers
thought was philosophy now we're saying
philosophy is also rational explanations
but rational explanations of what what
we're seeing is rational explanations of
reasons and purpose why someone does
something and it's a
bread and butter it's a building block
is the concept okay so this is
uh what we're proposing this is how we
look at things in this channel
and you don't have to agree i'm just
saying that's how we are going to look
at it here so when you bring things in
here
you may be tempted to bring things from
you know what uh people think in the
past what they thought uh philosophy was
and that's not what we believe or
consider philosophy here
okay so keep that in mind okay
and just as a final point on that is
that if you go to the stanford um
encyclopedia of what philosophy
the only word you won't find defined is
the word philosophy
so we have no idea what that
encyclopedia is about because they don't
have a definition for the word
philosophy
don't take my word for it look it up
you'll find it
the encyclopedia
of philosophy does not know it does not
define a philosophy and so they don't
have a
definition or an analysis of what
philosophy is
so since they didn't
i do
okay philosophy rational explanations of
purposes and call and reasons now we
don't do
purposes and reasons you know the whys
here why someone did something we do the
hows mechanisms okay we want to explain
because we do physics we want to explain
how the universe works
mechanistically
and some people say well you can't
explain that there's no way it's so
complex we cannot even imagine how it
works
and here we take the opposite position
we say that the universe is so simple so
simple
even a baby can understand it that's how
simple it is
i mean uh just think of it for a second
okay
uh what do we have out there
rocks we call them planets um
asteroids comets stars
what are we gasses
what are we talking about
we're talking about inert matter
just running around
you know uh we have these stars called
uh like our sun
and they have all this fire okay
whatever that is however it's created
and around them you have all these
planets going around
and
you know and also the asteroids and so
on
how difficult can it be
we're talking about essentially a
campfire
and a pebble going around
two entities
how difficult can it be
and the only issue there is that people
can't see the mediators
because if we had god's eyes and we
could see the mediators it would all be
over we'd say wow that's so simple
kindergartners can understand that
because we can see everything now
the only reason we ended up with
mathematical physics and all the
irrational explanations of mathematical
physics
i hope i'm still online
is that
is that we can't see the mediators
that's the whole issue
you know gravity when a pencil falls
down i like to do the experiment
why is it magical only because you can't
see the mediators
same with magnetism you know uh
how many how many objects do i have just
two objects two
uh the two black round things there
those are um
those are the magnets
and you know there it is it gets stuck
and i like to do this you know separate
them and you can see i'm not pushing it
okay and as soon as i let go of it
it falls in there
there it goes okay here it goes again i
let go of it
and so the only reason this is magical
is we can't see the mediators if we
could see the mediators this would be
kindergarten stuff you know we'd be
laughing at ourselves okay so so this is
the issue the issue is that
physics is about giving explanations of
mechanisms and in order to do these
mechanisms you need to identify the
invisible what
objects that serve as mediators
and if you don't do it with some
invisible object thing
entity body
substance whatever you want to call it
you're in essence
explaining with
black magic
okay so it's that straightforward okay
so that's our position here anyways uh
we say there's been a major paradigm
shift no particles or waves what we have
is light and gravity are mediated by
helical dna like ropes
what am i talking about well uh let's
just go slowly on this this is the
difference between what mathematical
physics
proposes and uh what the rope hypothesis
proposes okay we're just saying that all
atoms in the universe all atoms in
existence are physically interconnected
that's never been proposed by
mathematical physics mathematical
physics only proposes that there are
discrete particles out there it turns
out that that's not even true that was
true only as long as classical mechanics
was alive
classical mechanics died at the
beginning of the
20th century especially in the 1920s
when they came up with quantum mechanics
and quantum mechanics
does not use particles
they use the word particle to refer to
concepts abstract concepts specifically
the wave function okay it's a number
that somehow collapses and turns into a
point which is another concept because
it has no length width or height no
through it's not 3d it doesn't take up
any space it doesn't have any size
it's just a concept that turned into
another concept because they're just
going to do math they're not going to do
uh physical
mechanisms okay they're not gonna meet
they're not gonna simulate anything with
physical mechanism so those particles
are really not particles but
that's essentially what they're talking
about
and uh also you know for your
information on that is that if you go to
the
standard model which is the official
version of mathematical physics
you won't find a single picture of any
of the particles
uh you won't even find a picture in all
of quantum mechanics not of the
subatomic particles you won't find of
the atoms themselves
and yeah you'll see the little
planetary model for explanations for
everything but as soon as you put a
mathematical physics physicist against
the wall and say or against the ropes
and begin pummeling him and you say okay
draw for me
the quantum atom is this the quantum
atom this planetary model and they'll
say no it ain't that's not
our mod that's not our
quantum atom
and when you say well what does it look
like well some will say that
they've never seen one they don't know
what it looks like in reality and it
escapes their imaginations
others will tell you you got to take a
course in
in quantum mechanics at the university
level to understand what it looks like
okay those are the answers you get
um and here's uh our proposal we're
saying that
this is the single thread that all atoms
uh are eventually um not only
interconnected but what underlies them
all is a single thread that makes up all
the matter in the universe and the ropes
that interconnect them it's a single
closed loop thread okay
and this is essentially what we're
saying we're saying that this single
closed loop thread
essentially coils out on itself okay
not that it started out this way but
we're just giving you the idea of how
how the universe is built okay and so
we're saying that if you take the single
closed loop thread and twist it on
itself eventually you end up with
what you see there interconnected atoms
which is what we're proposing and there
on the bottom
left you'll find the model which is a
the basic model which is two atoms
connected by
a rope-like entity that uh expands it
the atoms expand and contract and by
doing so they twist the rope
and that's gonna be and those torsions
are gonna be what we call
light
okay this also helps us explain gravity
because now we have all atoms in the
universe interconnected and so you don't
have really what is known as action at a
distance
okay
uh it's not that there is action at a
distance it's that we can't see the
mediators that interconnect
the atoms
okay and so yeah it seems so the this
pencil is made out of atoms but we
cannot see the ropes that interconnect
every one of these atoms to every atom
that makes up the earth okay so that's
that's the argument that's the theory
okay
that's what you gotta debunk okay
and you don't debunk let's see uh well
i'll get to some of your questions later
on okay i just hope i'm still online
okay so
where does this take us we take it takes
us to
definitions of two uh
specific words
that have never defined for the purposes
of physics
not a single book
of physics textbooks of physics on
planet earth
begins by defining what an object is and
what existence is what exist means
and physics is the science of existence
physics deals with
what exists out there tries to elucidate
what exists especially in that invisible
intangible world of mother nature's
mother father universe god whatever
whoever you believe in okay and so we
need to define these two words object
and exist because they form the
foundations of any physical
interpretation
okay
and so what is an object it's not that
which you can touch or see
it's that which has shape
shape is a universal property of all
objects okay on the other hand see and
touch you can't see and touch
all objects or old things we can't even
see an atom
we can't maybe we can touch it but we
don't know if we did or not
you know depending a hydrogen atom can
you touch a hydrogen atom well
you know you go like that and you say
well i don't know if i touched it or not
because you you feel no weight on it or
anything you know but for sure you can't
see it okay
and we can't see the air
and you can't touch
the table that's on the other side of
the planet let alone uh you know one on
the other side of the universe so that
is all an irrational definition it's
also an irrational definition why
because
uh you need two objects to do see or
touch that means you need an another
object to define a word object
and then you have to define
nouns before you define verbs because
only a noun an object a thing can do
motion
so before an object can see or touch
meaning it's going to move it's going to
do something
you have to have an object and so again
you have to define the nouns before the
verbs you got to define the thing before
the motion
okay so for those reasons the definition
uh used by mathematical physics and by
just about everybody out there see touch
is irrational okay
and so all you can do is propose a
definition for these two words object
and exist
and you got to defend them you can't
just say well majority of people in the
world believe in it that's what we've
always used you know tradition and
that's what my teacher taught me
authority you know etcetera etcetera it
doesn't work that way not in science
that's the way it works in religion okay
so now here you gotta define defend your
definition
okay uh what are the typical uh
rejoiners rejoinders that um
people raise against the rope model and
here you have them okay this these are
the typical ones okay that i have gotten
over the last
13 years at least okay and so it goes
like this see that's the first one you
know say how come we can't see these
ropes
uh or they say touch you know how do
they avoid tangling you know you have
the ropes the the
gazillions of ropes we're talking about
an unimaginable number of ropes in fact
that's the next one quantity are you
saying there are trillions and trillions
and trillions of ropes crisscrossing
around me
yeah we're saying that there are
gazillions of ropes
gazillions means uh
well go figure out how many
how many zeros that got gazillions
there's gazillions of ropes in the
universe in fact there's gazillions
of stars
are you going to question the number of
stars
and
stars have tons of planets you know i
think there are more planets than stars
out there are you going to question the
number of stars
and each planet each star is made out of
gazillions gazillions of atoms are you
going to also question
you know how many atoms are in in this
uh making up for example the earth
with
it's gazillions
and so
you know we're not used to these
quantities so whenever people suddenly
you know wake up and say oh you're
saying there's gazillions of atoms here
on earth
well yeah have you just woken up
yesterday or what
yes there are gazillions of atoms here
on earth and nobody questions that
and now you say well there's gazillions
of ropes crisscrossing oh hold it you
mean there's gazillions of ropes
crisscrossing yeah that's what i mean
just like there are gazillions of atoms
there's gazillions of ropes
and you say then again you know how do
they avoid tangling
and i'll get to that in a minute okay so
let me continue other people talk about
belief they say what experiment do you
propose to run to prove their existence
you know the existence of the ropes
aha so uh we can't see or touch these
roads because they're intangible they're
invisible but you want to go to the lab
run an experiment to detect them somehow
to say ah there's the world
what you're trying to do with your
experiment is try to have god's eyes
and uh good luck with that one no you
can't see them but i'll get to that also
in a minute okay all of them together
i'll get to the other women together
together okay uh some people troll and
they say what do you mean by shape
and then what do you mean by mean and
what do you mean by the way or by and
you know i mean you know they just want
to uh
hound you to death same for you to
define every word in the dictionary
because you need this other word to
define this one and so on down the line
and so no we don't do that in science we
don't care about that we only define
those words that are crucial and the
context here especially in the
context of object
is that we either go with a shape or we
go with a c touch that's the only
context because what mathematical
physics uses and what almost everybody
out there in fact i think everybody out
there uh for example the electric
universe or the john chappelle society
all these dissidents and and the
establishment they all use the same
notion see and touch
and so we either go with c touch or
shape we do not need to know to the
perfect
uh
you know ultimate infinite
perfection what see touch and shape mean
okay
so it stops there it's a question of cr
which criteria you're going to use are
you going to use shape or c touch and if
you've got a better criterion than that
like you know mass volume or whatever
bring it on we've got we can take care
of you too
okay
and uh then we have creationism how did
did or do the ropes come into existence
they think that
space empty space can turn into a
physical object you know spontaneously
acquire length width and height and it
turned into a rabbit or whatever okay
and in this case the rope
uh no uh space cannot turn into matter
matter cannot turn into space period
we're done that's
a rational one person understands that
an irrational or religious person they
don't understand that because they're in
this world of spirits and energy and all
this other stuff
mechanisms so gravity is a stretching of
ropes
absolutely not that's not how it's done
it's done by aggregation and we'll get
to that in a few minutes okay but let's
uh
answer this with one
fell blow okay here it is okay we have
it here okay why don't you ask these
questions of dr quantum and professor
relativity okay
uh you say how can we how come we can't
see these roads well how come we can't
see these wave functions
did you ever think about that did you
ask
the
powers that be in quantum mechanics
about that how about touch how can two
particles be at the same place at the
simultaneously that's what quantum says
quantity are you saying there are
trillions and trillions trillions of
particles and waves around me
okay
so
how many waves are around us how many
particles how come you never question
quantum about that okay how about belief
well we have what experiment do you
propose to run to prove their existence
prove the existence of these wave
functions that turn into particles prove
the existence of waves how do you prove
that i mean you're going to go to a lab
and say yeah there i see it i can touch
it is that what it is you're going to do
it through seed touch
is that how you're going to prove it
definition they say you're doing
philosophy well for that you got to
define what physics is and what
philosophy is and as we all know now
stanford encyclopedia of philosophy
probably the number one uh source in the
world does not define the word
philosophy because they have no clue
okay they never thought about defining
the word philosophy
creationism how did big bang come into
existence okay i mean you say how did
the rope come into existence we're
saying it didn't it was always there but
why don't you ask the people in big bang
how they came into existence and they'll
give you the run around they'll say
what's an unscientific question
because we can't prove how it came into
existence
and about the mechanism well so gravity
is the bending of a concept called space
time is that what you're just suggesting
okay so uh yeah you gotta ask these
questions
first of um
uh general relativity and quantum
mechanics when you finish over there
then you can come over here now some
people will say well i don't believe in
quantum mechanics or relativity or
whatever uh i don't care
first
you go and attack them and show why
they're wrong or irrational like i say
and then when you come down here show me
first your theory so that we have a way
of comparing especially what's going
through your mind because we need to
find out what's going through your mind
in order to find out you know if you're
a rational person
and so first you got to propose your
uh theory your assumptions
and and then we can compare notes
okay we'll compare your notes against my
notes and then maybe we can apply john
avoca right okam's rule
or
just bill gates rule of irrationality if
you're moving concepts around or
defining words in such a way that you
can't use them consistently okay so all
these things have to go in that order if
you're going to attack the rope model
first attack quantum mechanics
you know attack yourself but if you say
well i don't believe in quantum or in
relativity no problem
then the first thing you got to do is
show your hands show your cards we need
to see your cards so that we can compare
you know the rope against whatever you
propose
very simple okay so if you get a
different idea how this universe works
uh no problem but you should be able to
defend it should be able to first show
your cards and then be able to defend
them okay that's the idea
okay a fellow comes over and he's a
flatlander one of these flatlanders he
says the following says you're living uh
on a flat motionless plane
uh i'm wondering if he has a square for
a brain yeah uh
you know you do that initial stick there
maybe one dimensional i don't know it
looks like a two-dimensional okay
and that's his living quarters
his house
okay yeah they believe that the moon and
the sun are about the same size and they
roll around each other
they're little
balls in the sky
maybe a few kilometers away
and they just go around and around
around
for no reason whatsoever
uh yeah what can i say you know
here's uh
what they usually propose uh for gravity
which is the issue there okay and now
everyone agrees there's like four
different theories from flat lenders but
i think the main one is that they
believe gravity is equal to electricity
in other words that gravity is
no different than electricity okay
and uh so no problem if that's what you
believe dear flatlander no problem uh
but you gotta answer these two questions
at least before you come in here and
attack anything especially
making a baseless statement like that we
live on a motionless plane not a flat
motionless plane
if you're going to propose electricity
you know first you got to show me how
you pull
with one-way flow of electrons which is
currently the notion that people have at
least mathematical physics has electric
universe has and all these other i think
the john chappelle
als group also believes in this they all
think that um in in what's his name uh
niels bohr's planetary model okay of the
atom and they think that uh electricity
is just a flow of electrons from one
atom to the other okay so
uh how do you pull if that's the case
how do you pull with
beads going from one in one direction
and then the other one is that even
before then you gotta explain or or
better yet you get a draw you know your
your model of the atom are you using the
planetary model
and if you are which is what
mathematical physics uses well then you
have to explain when that bead doesn't
spontaneously fly out of the atom or
fall to the nucleus okay what keeps it
in that yellow region which are the
orbitals or uh
energy levels whatever you want to call
them okay what keeps them there uh why
are they stuck in that region okay so
that's what you gotta explain
and hopefully you show a physical object
that connects
your little bead
to the proton
the electron bead to the proton bowling
ball as i call it okay you gotta explain
that because if you cannot explain that
you cannot even talk about electricity
because you you're not finished with
your hypothesis you're not finished with
uh imagining your own atom
so the your atom is the first thing you
got to draw and then from there
explain with your atom electricity and
then you can show maybe how
electricity pulls on something
very simple no positives or negatives we
want to see a physical mechanism you
can't say well this north pole that
south pole this is west pole east pole
we don't care about that uh or e or you
know
uh you can say positive negative a and b
x and y we don't care
you gotta show us a mechanism so you
gotta show us what's happening at each
pole okay
and
why
you know what causes the physical
mechanism that causes something to be
attracted to something else for example
in this case the pencil you know
apparently it's attracted to the center
of the ear it's certainly attracted to
the table but we all know that you know
if you do it outside side it falls it
tends to fall to the ground to the
center of the earth never falls to the
sky right you let go of it there it is
it falls downwards and so
you gotta explain with your electricity
without using positive and negative
right no energy no concepts no field e
thingy no messy thingy you get explained
with physical objects you guys you got
to draw your physical mechanism in fact
you should keep your mouth shut and just
make a movie of your physical mechanism
we watch it we should explain it just
like someone who would explain why the
window broke and he makes a movie of a
brick going through the window and say
okay we know how the window broke
the brick went through the window broke
it we're done that's that's what we want
that's what we're looking for a
mechanism how the window broke this is
the same thing we want a mechanism of
how that pencil felt to
the table it all has to be illustrated
video is even better because it's a
dynamic
thing that happened a phenomenon okay
so we want to see a mechanism don't talk
to me about energy don't give me any
equations don't talk to me about
positive and negative we want the
mechanism a movie with everything
identified all the objects identified
okay if you can't do that if you're just
gonna say well here's the equation
here's the concept that did it
you're doing
uh gravity you're doing physics with
black
magic
if you have no mediator
okay so i don't care if you push it with
particles or what no problem but there
better be particles real particles don't
tell me it's a concept that pushed on
the pencil okay
that's the point
okay uh
so um
uh here's uh what a person who um
wants to explain
uh gravity like in this case the
flatlander he said that gravity might be
electricity or whatever this is what a
person who tries to explain gravity has
to explain and uh this is uh mr richard
muller he's a professor or was i think
he's maybe he's retired now i don't know
emeritus
yeah from berkeley
and
he this is one of his classes and this
is what he says
about what causes what a person who has
to explain
gravity right has to explain you know
this is this is what you gotta explain
here it is okay give me a second here
let me turn it on okay because this uh
gonna be
uh
uh mr richard muller speaking here it
goes i hope you can hear him okay i hope
i'm still online here goes
the force of gravity is actually a force
of attraction between mass
so for example if you have the earth
with its big mass here and then and you
have you
with your little mass here
that every atom on the earth
is pulling on every atom of you
you're also pulling on it
on the other hand a lot of atoms here
you're pulling on you're pulling on all
of them amazing thing about gravity is
it goes right through things
i hope everybody heard that
okay please let me know if you didn't
okay i hope you heard uh
mr richard muller explain to you what
needs to be explained and here it is in
uh summary okay this is what what he
said essentially he says for example if
you have the earth there's a big mass
here and you have you with your little
mass here every atom on earth is pulling
on every atom of you you're also pulling
on it the amazing thing about gravity is
that it goes right through things
that's what you have to explain
okay so you have to explain
how
what mechanism you propose physical
mechanism where
gravity goes through things you know you
can't put a shield in front of you to
protect yourself against gravity okay
and then the second one is that uh what
you need to do is explain how every atom
on earth is pulling on every atom of you
okay
do we have that okay
you have to explain two things okay
let's see if we got it straight
how gravity goes through the wall you
have a wall in front of you it doesn't
help you
you know you can't protect yourself like
you know if there's if there's a wall
um and you're falling behind the wall
gravity will pull on you and the wall
together towards the center of the ear
like if you're falling from an airplane
and here's the wall below you and you're
behind the wall you say well i'm
protected because gravity can't reach me
because
the uh
you know the
wall is there to protect me no you both
fall
you cannot put a shield in front of you
to protect yourself against gravity
because gravity goes through things so
you have to explain that one and the
other one is how is it that every atom
on earth pulls on every atom of you
do you have that
okay
and so under the rope model here it is
okay here's a dynamic version okay
there you can see it
it's going to start in a second here
give it a second here so it starts from
the beginning
okay
you're trying to leave the earth with
your little spaceship
and
your
ropes
are extending and you can see uh what's
happening to the
ropes in general okay
what's happening essentially is all the
ropes converge upon a point and it gets
elongated and here you see it uh the
angles okay
give it a second here you look at what's
happening to the angles of the ropes
okay that's that's what we're saying
that's that's the argument that's the
theory okay
so let's start the beginning you see
what happens
to the angles there
uh with the red lines you can see what's
happening to the angles
okay as you get farther and farther from
the earth
the angles of the rope uh approach
zero or you can say even 180 degrees
okay
so that's the theory okay
you know close by
the ropes fan out farther away all the
ropes come together and gravity is weak
so
as you approach the earth you have an
acceleration of gravity because the
ropes are fanning out meaning they're
not superimposed upon themselves
because when you were far away they all
formed a single coaxial almost
and as you approach an object such as
the sun a celestial object the ropes fan
out
and now your acceleration is faster
faster and faster and faster
and remember every atom in your body
is connected to every atom on earth
so
this is the idea okay and so this
morning when i woke up
i uh decided to
make uh well uh i
loaded up
a um a little song
for you okay it's a little song
and i want you to hear it because it'll
help you remember
of
the fact that all things in the universe
are interconnected it's got to do with
this little fellow here okay
yeah i hope you can see them okay
okay and uh so we're gonna explain
gravity
or better yet interconnectivity okay
with this little fellow okay and so i
created a little song
for you and i want you to listen it
you should
sing the song every day so that you
remember the rope hypothesis okay
and here let me turn it on in a second
here
here it goes okay listen carefully here
it goes
[Music]
[Music]
okay so if if if you remember to sing
that song every day you'll know that
everything in the universe is
interconnected just like your whole body
is interconnected one thing is connected
to the other one okay
and as long as you have physical
interconnectivity across the universe
you can explain action at a distance
because there is no action at a distance
it's that everything is physically
interconnect
okay so let's get on with some of the
questions people raised uh
and they have to do a little bit with
this extinction thing which we also do
on this channel okay we did it
throughout this whole year what we
propose we're proposing that we're the
last humans on earth last generation of
humans on earth we don't have too much
too long to go okay
i don't know when it's going to come
down hopefully it's not in the year 2022
even though there are some hot spots in
the world that could create incidents
that get out of hand one of them is in
taiwan right now and the other one is in
ukraine
and so we have to keep a close eye on
that and just pray hope
that the
politicians and the military you know
reach an agreement at the negotiation
table
and
don't go for their holsters okay
let's just hope
for otherwise this will be the last year
okay
okay so this file says the first step of
your hypothesis
is social the human loses trust in each
other and the trade ends
okay
once the trade is over billions of
people will die of hunger starting from
the mega metropolises
the coup de grasse occurs uh for genetic
causes that is the systematic reduction
of genetic diversity genetic diversity
is critical for a population to adapt to
changing environments
wonder where he got there
if a heavily selected and low diversity
strain like fish populations grown for
aquaculture is introduced into the wild
population
it will reduce the population's ability
to adapt to changes
okay so uh
that's how he starts he continues here
he says your hypothesis is that an
overwhelming change that leads to
billions of deaths in our peace
in our species will mean that the
remaining ones will have to adapt to the
environmental change
and i want you to listen to these words
that he's using okay like adapt the ones
that i underline you know
environmental change what is he talking
about
or from a modern technological
environment to an older more natural
environment and this will crush it
bringing the human species to extinction
planned extinction the word plan means
that dna is by nature
programmed to destroy itself in a
species if this has been replicated for
a certain number of times and for a
certain number of laps around the sun
tell me bill what did i not understand
well what can i say this poor fellow
this poor fellow didn't understand
anything i mean he didn't get one right
okay so so obviously he's got a major
problem in understanding i think part of
it is that uh english is not his first
language so that's
understandable from that point of view
but this is more than that i think
he's not listening
he's not uh it all goes from one ear to
the other and there's nothing in between
to stop it
okay so uh this is where i start i'm
saying uh people like that needs to be
educated okay and
so
we we have to find out
what his problem is
and his problem is that he better
understand quickly because otherwise one
of us two will die and here we have uh
mr faulty for those of you who know him
okay
and he's gonna
tell it like it is okay so give me a
second here okay
and here goes
please please try to understand before
one of us dies
let's hear it again okay
now please please try to understand
before one of us dies
and why not one more time
now please please try to understand
before one of us dies
okay so please try to understand before
one of us dies
okay and how do we cure that when people
have problems in understanding we do
have a method for curing that on this
channel okay
and we'll let mr faulty uh you know um
explain that to us as well
uh he's gonna
do it
with his car he's gonna explain it to
his car how he how he
disciplines his car right that's it
you've tried it on just once too often
right well don't say i have warned you
i've laid it on the line to you time and
time again
this is it i'm gonna give you a damn
good thrashing
okay
so uh that's how we teach people in fact
uh we have the bill gatey
um school of physics right and this is
our motto here it is okay
uh at the bill gates school of physics
we teach with a baseball bat okay
so uh just be aware you know i
hear a baseball bat is too big so what i
use is my dough roller okay that's how
we teach here okay
so yeah
sometimes uh
we need to use a little bit of uh
physical
involvement
so that people understand okay so let's
get on with what this fellow said he
said uh first one he said first step of
your hypothesis is social
so we have to educate him on the first
line itself okay
what is a hypothesis okay and here it is
okay
okay here it is
science
is about rational explanations okay
scientific method includes hypothesis
what are hypotheses they're assumptions
okay
they include the objects the definitions
and the statement of the facts
essentially the initial scene the first
frames of your film okay because that's
your starting point for your theory so a
hypothesis includes objects definitions
and assumptions of about what happened
what is a theory hypothesis is not a
theory theory is not a hypothesis they
have nothing at all to do with one
another a theory is an explanation of
how it happened in the case of physics
right the mechanisms and causes in the
case of
philosophy it's explanation of why it
happened purposes and reasons a
hypothesis sets the stage for the
explanation founded upon it okay
so um
what you have to understand is that your
notion of hypothesis is already
irrational and if you look it up you'll
find all kinds of definitions for the
word hypothesis one says it's a
prediction another one says it's a
theory another one says in an assumption
they've got all these different notions
of what a uh
hypothesis is the questions you have to
ask
a whole bunch of stuff that has nothing
to do with the hypothesis okay
hypothesis is the set of assumptions and
they include the objects in case of
physics right the objects the
definitions
and your starting point in other words
the initial scene or your statement of
the facts not the facts because we don't
know what the facts are mother nature
knows what actually happened but she's
got that in her uh file cabinet you know
we have no way of reaching the file
cabinet all we can do is
make a statement of the facts of what we
think the facts are
and again you know you have a prosecutor
and a defense attorney sometimes they
won't agree on what actually happened
and that's what we're talking about each
one has his version of what happened and
based on that of what they think
happened they on and that's gone and
that is what they're going to base their
theory their explanation their case okay
so that's the issue so first learn what
a hypothesis is okay so that's the first
one and he says a human loses trust in
each other and trade ends
absolutely not that's not what uh what
this is about
okay so this uh this is what we put in
there we say that
uh first a hypothesis is not a theory
okay and then trade does not die because
of trust okay it's got nothing to do
with trade
with trust the fact that trade dies it
has to do with the global economy cannot
grow forever
so get it right has nothing to do with
trust
we're talking about trust in money
people lose we'll lose faith and money
once the economy falls apart because
what does that mean means money is no
more money money has no value and
because of that people lose not faith in
other people but they lose faith in the
uh in the dollar in the euro in money
itself you know even in bitcoin forever
gold whatever okay so that's the issue
and then uh the other issue is the coup
de gras for genetic diversity he says
genetic diversity is critical for a
population to adapt to changing
environments
not in this channel
not in this channel so please do not
mention that ever again
that's also that's only true
in the glow in the world of
paleontologists and geneticists and
we're saying these people have no clue
whatsoever about anything
not a single geneticist on planet earth
not a single paleontologist on planet
earth ever figured out how extinction
happens here we are 200 years later
after george couvier invented the
discipline and not a single geneticist
not a single paleontologist can tell you
how
species disappear
and uh even worse than that you know in
the case of geneticist you know what is
a geneticist geneticist is just a bean
counter
or what uh mr rutherford would say
um is a stamp collector you either do
physics or you do stamp collecting
a geneticist is a guy who knows how to
count atoms
maybe molecules
they can tell you something about
chromosomes
but he can tell you what what he sees
there
he sees through the sems and he comes up
with these machines that can read all
that stuff he doesn't even need to read
himself and he counts base pairs
and that's so far he's a bean counter so
far he's a lab boy he's a technician
he's not even an engineer
okay
an engineer is a scientist or supposedly
he's supposed to be and a scientist is a
guy who explains
he's got to figure out what actually
happened and how to explain what
happened
and what did the geneticists come up
with well they say uh we found two
percent commonality between
um
neanderthals and humans and so
the reason they disappeared is they had
sex
that's the kind of answers geneticists
give you swantipavo at the max planck
institute is the guy who created that
theory essentially he didn't create it
but he's the guy who made it popular and
that's the one that's the ruling theory
for how neanderthals disappeared
and so yeah all these paleontologists uh
geneticists they have no clue whatsoever
about their own
disciplines
so uh don't put their words in my mouth
okay
so it says genetic diversity
this adapt to an environment the fact
that
all they come up with is that yeah you
need to have like if you have inbreeding
the problem with that is that you're
going to be more susceptible to
environmental changes or to diseases
that's not what we say in this channel
get that straight that's not our
argument that's not our theory
okay
what is our theory inbreeding produces
[ __ ] children
and that's in a nutshell okay it's a
little more involved than that but just
so you can see the difference we're
saying that you can't continue
inbreeding like humans have for 200 300
000 years and expect to produce children
who come out physically or mentally sane
at some point you're gonna have uh what
do we have uh we have siamese twins
people with two heads two two elbows
whatever
uh
you know i see them in plants i raised
plants and i saw uh five in one of my um
peach trees five siamese
and and why because we are in
forcing them to inbreed in fact in some
cases like
we're trying to produce seedless grapes
and what we do is we just cut
you know if you've seen how grapes are
grown it's just uh cloning that's what
it is you you take a branch from here
and you plant it over there
that's how
grapes are being grown and so we're
liquidating all that stuff very quickly
you know
we're helping them achieve
this uh this point where they have no
genetic diversity because they're all
clones of each other you can continue
cloning
humans or anything else
and expect not to have [ __ ] children
after several generations that's what
happened in calhoun's experiment that's
what happened to the amish the amish
after 300 years of inbreeding right they
were not completely free when they you
know when they came to the to america
for example in the 1600s they were
already part of the human race and they
had been around for 200 300 000 years
now here they are
they go into these little communities
and they start having lots of children
over the centuries
and guess what now they're having mental
and physical problems people
kids being born with six fingers
you know and uh so this gives you an
idea you can't have inbreeding because
it results in [ __ ] children in
physically handicapped children that's
the issue it has nothing to do with the
environment it has nothing to do with
diseases with what you eat with climate
change with peak oil none of that
it's got only to do with the fact that
you can't inbreed because you're gonna
have [ __ ] children
you don't have to believe it
that's the argument that's the theory in
this channel okay we're not asking you
to believe but we're asking you to
understand that we're not talking about
what adapting to the environment or
diseases or whatever okay so you got to
understand that he didn't understand
this either okay
and then uh what was this other argument
here well let me show you first
this is cajon's experiment okay
and again he showed in a very short
while a period of two years
how uh eight mice eight uh four couples
um
with which is what is he started with
this was the fountain
uh founders effect okay he put
uh eight mice four couples in a closed
pen which was uh
about um
i think it was like two meters tall
maybe
and uh
about two meters all around you know two
meter by two meter by two meters by two
meters okay so it wasn't very big and in
there he put these eight mice and they
just reproduced
and by the time you get to you know like
the middle generations there after about
a year
there were about 2 000 of these mice all
from the same stock from the same
parents or grandfathers
and eventually you know they ended up
falling all the way to extinction
why because they did not reproduce well
let me here's a summary okay here's
calhoun's
summary okay
okay
uh vice became autistic they became
homosexual
he's i think the first one or one of the
first ones to produce homosexuality in
the lab
mice lost interest in sex females weaned
their offspring early and a lot of the
children were killed by others
females became more aggressive and mice
became more violent in general and
so calhoun he was a psychologist he
concluded that the experiment was an
analogy for what is happening to humans
look around you you'll see these same
symptoms
in our society and of course a lot of
psychologists out there say well we're
different than the mice uh you know
we're not the same as all these uh
animals uh why because we have uh
intelligence they think that makes a
difference okay maybe it does
i don't think it does okay uh the fact
that
you know
we we have all these uh
the fact that we can foresee events the
fact that we have intelligence we have
technology people think that's an
antidote to extinction and to these
types of problems they're not
okay
uh
the cause of a mass extinction
cannot be overruled by intelligence by
technology by the ability to foresee
events and react to them
nothing nothing humans can do
to change
extinction the extinction of mass
extinction okay
that's the argument in the site again
you don't have to believe it that's what
we argue here
and then here we have uh he says your
hypothesis that an overwhelming change
that leads to billions of deaths caused
by environmental change again nothing to
do with that but then he says planned
extinction like saying you know um like
there's some kind of uh god or
or
mother nature whoever planned it uh
had a purpose
uh
already planned it in advance and says
oh we're gonna
make sure that in this case he's saying
the dna by its nature is programmed to
destroy itself
no that's not what it's about okay
absolutely not we're not saying that
that's going to happen what we're saying
here is something else we're saying that
uh first of all
we're not going to die in a background
extension which is you know the genetic
diversity slash overturning of the
population pyramid those are the two
mechanisms that cause a background
extinction we're we humans right we're
our species is going to die was going to
disappear in a mass extinction that has
to do with food
why does it have to do with food because
we produce food thanks to money
what's that got to do with
money in a sense that well the global
economy cannot grow forever and at that
point
you can't just keep producing money
which is what we're doing now the this
this is the monetary
aspect the monetary
policy that uh all these governments are
implementing they're just creating money
and by creating money all you're doing
is
uh diluting the salary of those who
collect salaries and wages
and so what happens is at some point
a lot of those people will have no
reason to go to work
which is already happening but uh you
know what happens is a lot of those
people will just make barely make it to
the end of the month they'll be able to
pay their rent or food and that's about
it and go back to work the next day
which is the life of a slave
it's a
better slave than
the pharaoh had for sure no doubt about
that but still a slave that means a guy
can only go to work
pay his rent put some food on the table
and go back to work
and
there's more and more people in that
category
and the more money they produce the the
nominally means the less real value
money has
and that's eventually going to affect
the entire uh world and what's going to
happen here is that you know at some
point especially the united states
government which is the american empire
all i'm saying is all that needs to
collapse is the american empire we don't
need to have europe collapse we don't
need to have china collapse russia
collapse
oh all that needs to collapse is the
american empire once the american empire
collapses not if but once it does
that's it
you know china can't sell europe can't
sell they die
and the whole world collapses suddenly
and the collapse is going to be
exponential
and what do we mean by collapse it means
that it's uh
very cool very swiftly people realize
that money has no value that it's just
either a number uh
printed on a
internet server somewhere or a little
piece of paper that you carry around and
any of those will have no value
whatsoever you won't will not be able to
trade
that you know that currency
for anything else bitcoin same thing
gold same thing you can bring a pound of
gold and people say i don't want that
stone
i'd rather have my banana
because a banana will be worth more than
all the gold on planet earth
because money will be no more no one
will accept it because he will not be
able to get rid of it because the next
guy won't accept it
okay because what are you going to trade
it for money
so no it's the currency the medium of
exchange that disappears when that does
nobody has any incentive to produce food
for the world to distribute it to the
cities the cities massively die because
no one produces or distributes food
whatever food that's on the planet we
all scramble for
and that's not going to last very long
maybe a few months
at the most
and that's it and after that we start
killing each other and we begin hunting
humans
and that's that's going to be the last
food cannibalism
okay so that's what we say that's gonna
happen here in this site okay believe it
or not we don't care the point here is
that that's the argument
okay uh fellow says even if we had
completely
services based society for humans with
robotics and ai doing all the
manufacturing style labor we would still
have an economy
the few people one percent who dominate
the 99 will not let a full economic
collapse happen and he just essentially
repeats that in the rest of it he's
saying that um
the rich people those who dominate the
elites
the illuminati the new world order folk
the filthy rich
any way you want to think of him or call
him he's saying those will not allow
the economy to collapse
and my argument is that it doesn't
matter what they want to do
it's what you can
do
see this is not about being a republican
or democrat or a communist this has to
do solely with one issue and that is
that humans have no solution
to
global economic collapse we're headed
that way we're buffalo streaming towards
the edge of the precipice
again getting to the edge
of the mountain okay
and we're rushing there and there's
nothing that we can do about it
uh because there are no solutions the
elites have no power to change what's
coming up
they can create all the money they want
they can you know uh juggle anything
they want you know do their juggling act
it doesn't matter they will not be able
to solve this problem this is not a
problem that humans can solve this has
nothing to do with intelligence with uh
foreseeing events
uh
tech you know being able to react to it
uh
so it's got nothing to do with
intelligence technology etc
nothing that humans can do about this
it's going to happen okay the collapse
of the global economy is a done deal
uh we cannot avoid it and so this notion
that the rich people will not allow it
to happen because they would lose their
uh
status their their you know their
privileges
it doesn't matter you know they won't be
able to do anything about it okay
okay fellow continues here and he says
says uh spreading speculative fear porn
about the future
billionaires have put themselves in
space many probes and rovers paving the
way towards colonization of the moon and
nearest planets
he actually believes that we're going to
go out into space and i don't know
colonize the the planets first and then
maybe the stars
is that what is all about
uh i don't think so you know i don't
think we'll ever get off this planet
and you know for me it's it's very easy
uh first of all we can't get to the
nearest star we can't get through a near
start because it's 4.3 light years away
that's a measure of distance
round-trip you're tired about nine years
and that's if we could travel at the
speed of light but let's concede that
just for sake of argument no problem
and nine years
i don't think nobody will take that trip
and what to go there and see what
another star system just like ours
and begin to colonize maybe with robots
right maybe we send the robots first
they let them do the trip right okay
fine
and they go over there and they build
the the
planet whatever plant they find the
third rock from the star over there you
know whatever it is
and it turns out that it has some
material some co2 and they turn that
into oxygen great now we can breathe if
we go there right
so we're going to make the trip all the
way down there right
to this place
and for what are we gonna have commerce
with that planet
uh every nine years they send us bananas
or
wheat or whatever or maybe iron is is
that what it's going to be about
and it turns out that here on earth our
population is declining in other words
it's increasing but the growth rate is
declining meaning
if everything goes according to plans or
according to how it's going now
mid-century we get to zero population
growth
so
do we have enough land on the planet for
more people
absolutely we could put a trillion
people on the planet we're only 8
billion people
we could put a trillion people
on the planet
800 billion 100 times more than what we
have now
we could put on the planet physically
okay
well let's not talk about resources yet
we're just talking about land space
right
uh there's enough room for all of us we
do not need to go to mars we do not need
to go to venus we do not need to go to
pluto or even beyond we have more than
enough space
here on earth
now resources well
we also have resources and resources
really is like uh mr friedman you know
chicago school of economics said it's a
question of money
for the right amount of money someone
will produce it and distribute it
sell it
okay so
we don't have a problem we don't need
another planet we've got more than
enough space
and resources right now for the planet
as it is
foreseeable future
maybe new technologies of some kind can
extract more oil from the ground if we
need more oil maybe we can produce more
food if we need more food
okay there's a lot of
things that we can do okay we can turn
the sahara desert into a
lettuce producing garden
we want
under the right conditions under the
right technology okay so all i'm saying
here is that we have enough space we
have we can create enough food given if
if we have the right amount of money etc
for that
food that you're selling
we don't need to go to another planet
there is no reason whatsoever to go into
another planet aside from the fact that
i doubt very much that we can get to
mars but assuming we could because that
is within
the possibilities okay
i think we have the technology to get
there whether we will get there's
another thing maybe extinction catches
us
uh by surprise a little sooner than that
but if we go to mars and and uh you know
put a station there
so he's going to live there five guys 10
guys 10 astronauts maybe 20.
what are they going to produce potatoes
like the guy who who got stuck on mars
and
started planting potatoes there is that
what we're going to do
are they going to import them to
to earth back again they're going to
trade
you know
think about it why are we going to build
a station on mars are we going to
terraform mars and live there and
breathe
the oxygen
on a planet that has much less gravity
which holds less
air around it assuming we could create
the air right let's let's concede all
these points so we create air it's going
to hold the gravity is going to hold
less air around the planet a thinner
sheet of air meaning you're going to
have less pressure
okay a lot of things are going to change
it's a planet that maybe is a quarter of
the volume of earth you know so i mean
are we going to move to mars
when we don't need it because we have
all the space and resources we need for
the upcoming generation here on earth
so no it's never going to happen because
going into space
is an irrational proposal
because it means that they haven't even
thought about the fact that
we already have everything we need here
on this blue
planet okay so that's the issue
okay um
fellow says
can we well i said this can we run the
world on entertainment because
everybody's now moving on to the into
the internet we're leaving even the
services that are you know hands uh
operated by hands like barbering uh
landscaping uh
uh you know um
for example restaurants hotels you know
you need uh people who make the beds and
so on all that
is disappearing and
where are people being
uh where are people going to well
they're moving on to the internet
they're all creating internet jobs
okay you create this and that and you
create ads and you get a check every
month from the
company that pays you because you put
some uh things that people like and they
all gave you hits and you get all these
uh this income from hits
and so everybody's moving from hands to
abstract internet which is primarily
entertainment and i was saying that can
we run the world on entertainment
meaning on internet alone and the guy
says as you can understand half the
population of the world china india
russia japan etc
they produce as usual and they think
about entertainment as usual the
entertainment is belonging to the
ignorant people of the european
continent and of course our cousins uh
in the americas in australia
and no
i don't think that's the case first of
all the entire planet china japan
included for sure
are into uh
internet
and they're into entertainment i mean
obviously you haven't been there you
haven't gone to these places or even
looked at their videos maybe you should
do a little research on what's popular
in japan and you'll find out that
they're even more advanced on
entertainment than even the united
states india have you ever heard of
bollywood
uh or maybe it's just misspelled maybe
it's just hollywood that they didn't
know how to spell very well
so look it up you'll find that
entertainment is alive and well across
the planet uh i came from south america
a little
while ago a couple weeks ago
and
entertainment's just as big over there
as any place else internet has taken
over the world
the entire planet every country okay
everybody wants to go in the internet
because it's a fast way of making money
uh bitcoin certainly stimulated that as
well you know everybody now is betting
on all kinds of uh coins out there
crypto coins so that also takes people
out of jobs and into this speculation
you know casino and at home you can pull
the one arm bandit at home
yeah
says you do you don't do predictions in
science meaning you know that's what we
say we don't do predictions but you
predicted extinction in this very video
okay it's not that uh it's a not a
prediction
and sometimes it's very hard to get that
through people's heads
the extinction theory
is an explanation that's what a theory
is
and you can only explain the past
so it's not a prediction it's got to do
with the past because you're focusing on
the wrong
issue the issue is explanation of the
mechanism of extinction
okay so we're explaining the past we're
explaining the dinosaurs died we're
explaining how the archosaurs died we
were explaining how the
ordovician uh animals and the um
what is it the carboniferous uh
amphibians and the
permian synapses die that's what we're
trying to explain we're trying to
explain how animals in the past died
and then we project this mechanism
mechanism word mechanism keep it in mind
mechanism okay we're extrapolating this
mechanism to humans and saying can they
avoid the same problem which is food
and turns out they can't
and so we're saying that because they
can't
humans are going to disappear the same
way
that the animals in the past died in
mass extinctions
okay we got it okay no prediction this
is not about prediction predicting would
be if i say look on the 1st of may of
the year 2030 humans are going to die
they're going to disappear the last
human is going to die on that day
i can't tell you that i don't do
predictions okay i do explanations i
tell you mechanisms that's what this
site is about as long as you stay there
um
i won't hurt you
okay we got that
okay another false ah speak for yourself
old man i'm starting to suspect bill
just hates to think people will go on
just fine without him
in other words uh you know when i die
humans die because yeah in a sense uh
all existence dies because i died
okay
his scrooge like personality man's
everything ends when he ends
well yeah that's a valid point okay it
could be could be that maybe i'm
overdoing it maybe
maybe i'm just a little pessimistic okay
and i'm saying well yeah you know since
i'm going to die i think everybody
should go with me
and essentially that is the case because
when i die
as far as i'm concerned you're all dead
too
you no longer exist for me
right um so yeah you can say that bill
because billy is close to the end of his
life then maybe that's where he got the
idea that
uh you know extinction of man is also
near its end
okay it's a valid point you you can
consider you can
factor that into your decision whether
to
believe in the theory but we're talking
about a mechanism here the point here
again is mechanism as long as you focus
on the mechanism
i promise not to hurt you okay
so please
keep your eyes on the mechanism and uh
in that sense it doesn't have anything
to do with me the other thing i'm going
to say is that
i've been peddling my theory for 20
years
i wasn't expecting to die you know 20
years ago
i didn't think i was that close to
my own extinction so no this extinction
theory has been around for 20 years and
i've been putting it on the internet at
least since what is it 2008 13 years
just like my
rope hypothesis
so um
no uh you gotta factor that in as well
okay final
points on uh the extinction uh things
here people person says uh talking about
uh homosexuality okay he's saying that
it's uh learned it's a question of
nature versus nurture some people
believe it's homosexuality is a nurture
issue not a nature issue you're not born
that way you're educated that way and he
says bamboozles numerous young boys
whose sexual development is then tilted
towards homosexuality so he's saying
that here comes this guy who's already
homosexual and because he rapes or
fondles or whatever a kid the kid
becomes homosexual as well that's what
he's saying
it is spread through sexual contact
specifically when an adult male
bamboozles an immature male
well
i take a different view
my theory or the assumption that i make
really assumption that i make is that
this is a genetically related issue that
after 200 to 300 000 years of inbreeding
we're going to get
garbage out of women's
wombs
so my only suggestion is women should
not have children because today we're
all clones of each other more or less
and the chances of getting a kid that is
born wrong both physically
or
physically or mentally sometimes both
right
are great
and especially if you happened at older
age especially if your husband uh
has problems with you know the fact that
he's got his
got a low sperm count or they're not
very active or whatever he's got
problems with his sperm
lots of problems with that lately so
right now it's not a good time to have
children right at the end of humanity
because uh first uh that kid's probably
gonna meet an early death
and you don't want to see your kid die
probably
and uh you might have to eat them before
your neighbor does
just like i said okay
and the other issue is uh more than
likely you're gonna have a kid that's
born wrong
okay so
what can i say i can only recommend in
that sense okay but yeah i'm saying that
uh
inbreeding leads to homosexuality it's a
primarily a genetic issue it's got
nothing to do or very little of anything
to do with education with someone
in someone raping a kid or the kid being
exposed to
homosexuality and starting to like it
you know and think of yourself if you're
heterosexual you know a normal person
and uh how did you learn uh
did they teach you to like if you're a
man right uh did they teach you to look
at girls
or was that like
king by itself
i can tell you my experience my
experience is you know i was attracted
to women for a very very young age and
so it came naturally
no one taught me okay neither my folks
neither at school
neither the kids uh
in my uh you know that were my friends
and so on no it just came naturally okay
yeah i don't know how to explain that it
it it was inbred
okay fellas can you talk about nuclear
weapons are they real or just made up as
after the atomic bombings of hiroshima
and nagasaki both cities were
repopulated very quickly when it should
have taken over a thousand years for
them to become safe
there are people who still do not accept
that
the bomb was dropped over these two
japanese cities
they don't believe a lot of them maybe
not the same people but a lot of people
out there don't believe we went to the
moon
and i guess you'll find people who say
no jfk never existed that that's that
was made in hollywood the two towers you
know uh
really including uh
building seven right which is more
important really but
they're still there you know i went to
new york the other day i saw him there
uh they never came down that was that's
a movie that they put in hollywood
so they don't believe a lot of this
stuff and much less are they gonna
believe stuff as you go farther back in
history yeah they might even say well
hitler did not exist stalin did not
exist
mussolini did not exist those there's
that that's all
nonsense that they teach us it never
happened it's the elites who are trying
to brainwash us
so this is what
some of these people believe okay that's
what they have in the back of their mind
well i'll give them an answer anyways
okay here's one answer okay that might
help you
straighten this thing up first one is
that you know there are lots of pictures
uh of these two cities after they were
bombed okay
and the other thing i want to mention to
you is that japan surrendered
immediately after nagasaki was hit
i wonder why
maybe you can answer that question okay
why didn't that the japanese surrender
so quickly when they were fighting tooth
and nail to the last moment and suddenly
they dropped these two bombs the first
one shocked them the second one to say
oh we're not going to have all of japan
destroyed and so the king you know the
emperor he took a decision says okay uh
we surrender they brought out the white
flags and kojo you know he committed
suicide and so on okay he was running
the show
okay but here's here's your answer okay
and it comes from uh i think it's the
guardian uh from london
uh an article and this is what it says
says uh weeks after hiroshima felt
the unforgiving force of nuclear fission
nature compounded the city's misery
makurazaki an unusually powerful typhoon
swept through the city on 17 september
flooding large areas and ruining many of
the temporary hospitals set up on the
outskirts the only good thing that came
out of it was that it washed a lot of
the residual radiation into the sea
says takanaka
tanaka after the typhoon radiation
levels fell considerably
and then same article later on says the
cancer rate among elderly a-bomb
survivors is high
so they did have
cancer okay
many a-bomb survivors have been fighting
various cancers and other illnesses
typically caused by radiation such as
heart problems cataracts and leukemia
right there are very few survivors who
have not experienced health problems
as they've grown older
so yeah the radiation did hit them they
stayed in the city
uh
and just in case uh you missed it uh
there was a
another
explosion nuclear explosion uh one in
japan okay uh
a couple years ago was it and the other
one in
in
russia okay
and people are still living in those
regions now are they going to have
cancer
yeah very likely in fact some people who
apparently there there's an uh theory
that some of the actors who did a
movie near nevada
i can't remember now all the little
details but they did
a movie over there and they were near a
testing
site for nuclear weapons by the i think
it was the us army
and
just by sheer coincidence a lot of these
actors later on famous actors later died
because of cancer
and so people say well all these people
were in that movie and they all died of
cancer and it was when they went were
close in this little town that was close
to
where the testing site was
so you figure it out yeah
the fact that you don't see the
radiation doesn't mean the radius and go
through you again see touch forget about
that
you know uh there's something hitting
your atoms
and it better be a physical object okay
we call that the rope
okay fell says electricity isn't an
object yet we can weigh a charged
battery is more than it does
it weighs more uh charge battery than it
does discharge
uh so what does that mean does that mean
that because of that
a
battery i'm sorry this thing we call
energy whatever it's got in there the
charge
is that a physical object just because
a battery weighs more before and after
i mean what does one thing have to do
with another are we going to define
um enter a charge as an object because
or are we going to find the word object
as that which weighs is that the
definition of object
okay
and do we have to weigh it in other
words uh it's not enough the table that
the klingons have is not an object
because you can't weigh it
and until you weigh it it's not an
object
is that your rationale
so no you can't say that because a
battery
uh weighs less
uh
when it's discharged then when it's
charged
that the difference is the thing you
call energy and because of that energy
is a physical object
that's not a good rationale
not at all means
you got problem guy okay
and
see i've got this this this
these individuals in general you know
they they believe that you know the same
same rationale they think that because
you know uh you
apparently weigh
more when you're alive than when you're
dead they say the difference is the soul
and the soul has weight and therefore
because it has weight it's a physical
object same rationale okay and so they
have
this is from traditional religions right
this notion
and they never identified the objects
because in order to identify an object
you have to have a shape you have to
point it you have to illustrate it they
never thought about that they just
thought in the abstract say oh i see a
spirit and so they have these notions
here i'll show you a couple okay these
are the notions they have
you know they say that when a person
dies okay you have the spirit
come out of their bodies and they say it
flies away and so that spirit has weight
because now the what's left behind
weighs less and so what was what left
was something that weighs more
and here you have another one you have
these spirits that fly around
okay and people believe in this stuff
they they believe in these spirits and
they call them energy they have all
these notions for it
uh here's another one okay
uh
uh someone leaving the body okay this is
what these people believe
okay
and so the question is whether
uh this comes from uh first of all
traditional religions whether this has
any um
importance in science
whether any person who brings this kind
of stuff uh talking about energy coming
out of a battery or soul or spirit or
whatever you want to call it coming out
of a body uh you know that dies or
whatever
this is all religion this these are
people who have no clue whatsoever about
science what are these people doing in
science is the question
you know
they're in the wrong field
they should stick to religion on sundays
and go pray and
and hope that their soul goes
up not you know north instead of south
that sort of thing
okay
okay fella says
no we have gravity
we have no weight
okay and that's because i said that
you don't have to weigh something in
order for it to have weight
something has weight already in outer
space you don't have to put it on a on a
scale and weigh it
everything in the universe already has
weight with respect to everything else
even though it's in the middle of space
okay
and uh so he says no what you have is
gravity not weight
okay and so
my god uh we have to bring the
motto again okay the motto bill gates
school of physics what is it we teach
with a baseball bat
so i'm gonna learn yeah
my poor god
what are these people doing in science
okay that's the issue
and uh yeah here let me show you
this is what this uh felt let me get
myself out of here before i bash him
over the head with something okay
uh yeah weight there's the equation for
weight okay
it's
the gravitational constant mass 1 mass 2
divided by distance squared we have two
masses in other words two objects and
they're separated by distance that's all
we have
that's weight it's a static concept okay
there is no motion
but uh they say weight is a force okay
and i say no weight is a tension
because it's only valid for a given
location in space
and israel says no that's gravity
no that's great because that's the
equation of weight that you're staring
at there do you see any requirement for
a scale in that equation
okay
it says weight is a vector quantity uh
weight has magnitude and direction and
actually weight
does not need weighing you weigh before
you weigh yourself okay so yeah uh you
already have a weight
uh anywhere on in in the universe with
respect to something whether it's the
earth whether it's the sun whether it's
pluto we don't care could be with
respect to a galaxy you're in the middle
of nowhere okay
uh you already have weight because of
the equation the equation doesn't say
anything about scale or about weighing
it says that if you have two masses for
example the earth and you
and you're separated by distance
especially you know from the center of
that uh
object that's celestial object then you
have weight that's the equation sorry
okay so you got to learn the basics okay
uh
you you know until you get a handle on
the basics uh maybe when you get to high
school
maybe you're still in kindergarten
trying to get to
first grade i don't know okay yeah
weight
has nothing to do with weighing okay
weight has to do with
separation between two objects they
already have weight you have weight even
even an asteroid in outer space has
weight
and you say that's gravity no he's got
weight according to that equation
and if you don't understand it well all
i can do is bat you over the head or ask
you politely to go
into religion
go go to sunday school you're in the
wrong field you're in the wrong
discipline
okay a fellow says
what happens with ropes when a new
person is formed from sperm and ang our
new roach generator with with the
additional cells
my poor god how can this be so difficult
no we cannot create
ropes you know here's a rope
okay this is just one rope this is a
macro world rope right just in case this
is not the yellow for a magnetic rope uh
the only thing they have in common is
just the shape so i use the rope as a
model as a simulation for the
electromagnetic road but this rope
cannot be made from space
and i'll give you here i'll give you my
magic wand okay it's bill gates okay
magic wand okay so you got the best
magic wand in the world
and
you go out there and see if you can turn
space
into
not only a robe you want something
simpler you know into a cube into a ball
whatever you want
i mean you you can't do it you can't
turn absolutely nothing that which has
no shape into that which has shape
we're done that's how simple it is so
now uh the ropes are not created they
don't come from nothing
okay they uh they've been there all
along and so that means that
all matter in the universe has always
been there it was never created by god
or by big bang
which is which are the two reigning
theories today that
almost everybody believes out there
okay hopefully new year the rope year
will change that okay
okay you said that uh last video that
the rope was intangible
yeah correct how does it bind anything
if it just becomes particles without
being tangible
that is what the tango question uh was
about
uh tango questions were about
oh my god let's go again uh should we
learn him
how can this be so difficult okay
yeah what's the issue the issue there's
a couple issues here the first one is
that
this thought believes that when we use
the word binding
and pulling
he's thinking that we're talking about
two objects the rope being a separate
object from
the uh
atom
like if you know you have like there a
hook
you know tied to the atom okay they're
bound yeah they're bound uh and so how
does something that is intangible pull
on something
uh that is tangible
that's that's his argument
and this is so simple and again this guy
is in the wrong field should be in
religion
should not stick around in science
anymore okay
here it is this is the construction okay
of
the atom
which is the rope which is the atom
which is the rope which is the atom
essentially one thread
goes into the center of the atom and the
other one goes around okay that's how
the atom is constructed according to
this side you don't have to believe it
that's the assumption okay that's why
it's called the rope hypothesis in other
words we're not talking about two
distinct objects there's only one object
in the universe that's the thread
essentially okay
when we talk about tables and so on
we're talking about
objects made out of atoms and yeah we
have to talk about something in physics
and so we use those as objects but if
we're going to go you know theoretical
about it we're gonna go down to the
nitty gritty that there's only a single
object in the universe and that's the
single thread that makes up everything
okay
and again space cannot turn into a
thread thread cannot turn into space
meaning the thread has always been there
in the middle of nothing meaning that
which has no shape which is space
okay
and uh so what's the issue here well you
have as you can see there at the bottom
okay you have one thread makes up one
part of the uh
atom which is the electron shell and the
other thread goes through and makes up
the
uh what we call the proton dandelion or
proton star it's like an urchin light
structure
uh all the threads
pointed uh
radially okay
and so and then on the other side
another
the ropes
the the two threads binding uh twine
again and turn into another rope
so it's not like we're talking about two
objects we're talking about a single
object so the notion of touching
that you have in your mind is only
between atoms so you got to put it in
the right context are you talking about
adam touching adam or are you talking
about this system which has nothing to
do with your notion of touching
there is no touching here because it's a
single
thread
that goes
to ropes to atoms to throats to atoms
what part don't you understand
and again uh
maybe you need some learning okay
hopefully hopefully next year
um
this we're one year away from 22.
hopefully next year uh you come to your
senses
either you come to your census or you
know you leave the discipline altogether
one of the two
i don't know why this is so difficult to
understand
anyways uh it's too late to do uh
questions i'm gonna take uh whatever you
folks ask there and try to answer them
next time meanwhile all i can say is
have a happy rope year okay well